hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom eternal I have
got all of the goodies except for one
which is a stupid suit point that I
didn't know that I didn't have when I
was going into the level and I didn't
feel like going back and doing the thing
but I got all the toys so I'm gonna show
off my little collection also I was
going through the old levels with a
cheat code inactive which makes it very
fun because I basically just took my
sword and went ham on everybody there so
this is my collection I've gotten all
the toys I've gotten almost all the
collectables I've gotten pretty much
everything that I need so I'm ready to
go into a deck which is supposedly
heaven and see what's going on there
also if you notice me I'm shuffling in
place and I'm going to be slightly out
of breath that's because I'm trying to
get a hundred thousand steps in today
you probably have already seen the video
with which this takes place but hey Here
I am I've got my Apple watch on my leg
and I'm just kind of like marching in
place just trying to get my steps up I
don't know what count I'm at right now
but it's three o'clock and I've got a
long way to go in terms of steps
I can't let Let's Plays get in my way
gotta stay fit gotta stay no matter what
but we're ready to do this so let's go I
don't think there's anything else that I
need to get I've gotten all of the the
Sentinel batteries and stuff like that
I've gotten every item in this area I've
gotten all of my suit upgrades are
basically done I mean I got what I can
there's probably gonna be a few more in
the next level but for now it's just I
don't know it's just what this is so I
got to play so let's do this
also it was amazing going back to the
old levels and just realizing how much
better I've gotten at the game in terms
of just learning how the game flows with
the crucible blade forged anew you begin
your journey to the con makers heavenly
realm of air DAC yes looks lovely to
stop her from gaining full control of
the slumbering icon of sin to reach the
maker world you must pass through neck
Raval city of the Damned oh that's what
this is at the core of the neck rival
towers the curstyn Citadel where inhuman
souls are sorted tortured and converted
into arjen energy at the towers peak
argent is transmitted directly to
attacked providing you with the only
known point of entry to the maker city
oh wow I love the crying guy here oh no
you're so sad I'm tortured yeah yeah if
you're tortured in hell maybe you
probably actually you probably didn't
deserve it depending on what the hell's
going on here
good to see you madhu duh sorry you're
feeling so sad but hey you know it'll uh
well it won't get better but uh I'm
pretty sure it'll won't get worse not
that that's anything to look forward to
this is gonna be a challenge there
really is just because I gotta do so
much all at once
and I gotta remember how to play against
people that probably aren't the worst in
the world and by people I mean demons
okay okay thinking thinking thinking
thinking thinking thinking thinking oh
god yeah you hurt okay that's okay
though
how do I play again I've completely
forgotten I think it's just because I
was playing with cheat codes but it's
okay ooh I will take em Oh at this point
I just want more balloon Bangi so that I
can bang more Bumi's and that's the only
thing whoo the music is nice in this
area I mean the music has been nice in
the whole area I don't know if I've
complimented the music enough in this
game or the landscape because my god it
is just beautiful III don't want anyone
to think that I think negatively of this
game just because I've got some nuanced
disagreements with the story here and
there to be perfectly honest if the game
is so goddamn good that's the only thing
I could possibly nitpick just because
the game oh wow hey hey oh I see I see I
see okay I gotta keep my steps up hey
hey hey hey hey
all right did I miss anything now okay
hey bud
you are al who hit me who dare hit me
you did you did much much much I gotta
remember to keep but steps every time I
get in a fight I always stop this may
not seem too important to you now that
you guys are watching it here but this
is a quest of mine and the only way that
I'm gonna be able to get to it is by
constantly remembering it okay so I
gotta go up there aha okay a neck revolt
part 1 the city of Mecca rule was built
in hell by the combined efforts of the
makers and Sentinel engineers designed
to produce a continuous flow of origin
energy constructed of stone and fell
steel on a foundation of uncounted
corpses that doesn't sound like a very
stable foundation sprawling fortress
funnels a constant stream of victims
towards Calabasas the sightless judge
this ancient demon is a rare breed
unable to communicate or move without
great difficulty how did it survive it
exists as an overseer of sorts awaiting
as cage is packed with the recently
slain are brought before it determining
which souls are candidates for the
Argent process operating not unlike a
large-scale slaughterhouse Necker ville
is divided into many sections the most
immediate accessible portion contains
the Abaddon pit an enormous chasm where
victims are herded beyond Calabasas the
argent where these souls are directed
deeper into the black fortress those who
he renders unfit are discarded as waste
their tortured souls thrown into the
burning sludge of the blood swamps now
that sounds like hell I was about to say
it sounds awesome it sounds horrible but
that's the kind of lore that I want
give me that lore ya hoo I spy with my
little eye something that is quad damage
ok there you are oh yes please Oh baby
you're going down dude oh my
God you never stood a chance he never
stood a chance
Oh none of you stand a chance oh not a
one of you stands a chance
oh no oh no you get chainsawed module Oh
No
oh that's so sad for literally all of
you oh you never stood a chance
well took care of that that was easy
alright there's a secret up yonder way
what secret pray tell is up you're
beyond this door you say hmm interesting
oh I can't make it okay there's got to
be something with this but where who
pity I didn't make it okay so not there
aha no it looks like just a door that I
would open eventually I'll come back to
it I'm not gonna get too hung up on the
secrets even though I have been getting
hung up on the secrets just because I've
been all about him lately but for now I
won't get to Oh God pick me oh that is
so cool look at that that is cool that
is horrifying oh my god hey you're
practically out do just fall you're good
dude you're good just fall oh no oh oh
no oh no it's horrible
alright do I go down sure seems like I
go down I think I go down alright push
button you got it buddy
ooh how about Bob Byrd whoa hey bud hey
hey hey hey hey enough of that nothing
that no no no no no no no no no Oh God
Oh just enough baby just enough did you
guys know that this place called hell as
far as I know it's full of scrubs just a
bunch of big bubble-blowing babies as
far as the eye can see
Hey No Hey well I didn't need to waste
that bullet on that cool oh I see yeah
oh I see it's a race pup easy barely hi
hey did yeah it looks a little cramped
in there oh my god what was that what
did I just see what was that some dude
just slip by there what the hell is that
oh there you go oh that's not that's
that I shouldn't be able to see that
okay oh I recognize those oh yeah those
were all over the walls in the original
doom hell yeah love that
the culling allows her people to
replenish their resources and survive as
you saved
that's too bad for her I am stuck I sure
wish I could see this beautiful God I
wish I could see this oh come on it's a
beautiful view oh don't worry I love
hanging by my neck in a cage sure wish I
could see what was in front of me oh
well whoa I just there's something in
front of me don't know what though
there I go okay look Ella Bess barely
I'm in calabasas shooting what at me
what Oh ah interesting
do I need to shoot you oh yeah I do and
these eyeballs are kind of tough oh
there we go
wow I'm falling why am i falling hi
I love turret mode on this thing this is
just so much power it's so much foot spa
oh so much foot spa so much hoot spa hey
bud I'll be right over there oh oh oh I
didn't realize that was that low on
health okay true that wasn't do what now
what do I need to do oh [ __ ] that brain
go boom
no no did I get it March in place step
step step step step all right I did it
any secrets here no apparently not how
many secrets would be here there's quite
a few what is this
hello oh hey don't walk in there but
it's not good for you all right
that sucks for you hey bud what are you
doing in a place like this oh is this
where you died all right
Skoosh love it oh yes
oh yes please Skoosh Oh miss charge
Skoosh
Skoosh Skoosh hey sweet oh boy another
suit point veg has given me points
they're giving it to me
why thank you sir oh I'm handsome too
well appreciate that and I appreciate
you know automap don't mind if I do
Wow now I've got everything seems like
there should be a way to go around there
but apparently not oh god they're just
stuff them in the walls that's so sick
oh that's nuts in the bones walls are
just made of bones oh my god oh god I
love this so much fire power oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah that's a good stuff there
we go there we go whoa where did I go
hope we're here am I going baby
damn damn damn what's wrong with you oh
you're so dead oh you're not dead
there's an hour trial on the scene whoa
that's not good there's an arts file on
the scene and I want to know where there
you are Bubba sorry goodbye see you
around buddy
damn he took a point-blank BFG oh trap
trap please come here you boom oh where
am I oh wow okay March in place March in
place March in place March in place
oh oh oh whoops almost fell and died
couldn't have had that dude this is
getting so good like just me I'm so good
okay now how would someone get in there
that's the question of the day there's
something going on there so some way
under here what is this that right there
that looks like the way to go but how do
you get there
what oh wait oh I see I see I see I see
I see I see okay down here pop there we
go oh oh I found a cigarette and then I
found this secret and then I'll come
back for this other one let's see if
it's gonna put a marauder at me or
something
that was it really just a hell night
that's all you're gonna give me Jesse
all night Wow what do you think I am
some kind of chump I think I can't take
a single hell night loser
gotta get my steps in and surprisingly
my Apple watch is reading my heart rate
on my leg
83 bpm it says I've only gone three
miles in like an hour in 30 minutes
which makes sense cuz like it's not
exactly like I'm doing super consistent
stepping but hey it's something it's
better than standing here do you want to
get fit just try to get a hundred
thousand steps in in a day right through
you my dude okay there's got to be some
good oh yeah there's a goodie over there
I've got tons of 1ups cuz of me going
through the previous levels and farming
them all so I just haven't been dying as
much oh my god oh my god I just noticed
the waterfall of blood down the stairs
holy crap oh dude the level design in
this game is nuts
I really appreciate they go they go all
out on the hellscape and I'm I'm so
there for it okay
it's really weird the way you're saying
it's almost like you're enjoying the the
thought of it is just to me it's kind of
creepy just a little bit creepy buddy a
little creepy all right hello off totem
nearby oh yes there is
oh yes where is it oh my god holy crap
yeah there is where is it I have no idea
holy crapola I see it I see it I see it
Jesus what a load of crap
yeah time before me to show my
handsomeness and kaboom love that that
was a great combo fur armor there and no
thank you I love it this is the first
time that I've really seen the original
doom echoing its level design and these
levels just the weird traps the weird
doors the different platforms it really
is reminiscing of the original game and
I love it the art team must have had a
field day designing these levels this
looks so fun just in terms of like how
much they're putting into it and also
just like the ability to to recognize
the the brutality of it it's nuts
and I love it whoo doom Hunter step step
step step get my steps in get my steps
and get my steps and get my steps in it
simple some steps and steps lots of
secrets okay
so there's something through this big
door but how do I get through the big
door huh
up here I can't reach that one minute 37
seconds later oh god of course god I
mean it's right there staring at me in
the face of course that seems obvious
now that I'm looking at it rightio got
it okay Green to green makes sense makes
a whole lot of sense
all right then well that's one oh there
we go
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow my knocking ow
oh you want to dance pretty man oh
really
ow who the hell wait Han whoa whoa whoa
easy there can that guy please oh my god
really stop you [ __ ] I hate you okay
I'm having a conversation with the
Marauder can you please just leave me be
there we go close one close one close
one that guy he was a bit smarter than
your average morado but it's still not
that good not good enough not good
enough from me even though I did lose a
life but that was to the other guy the
other lady the snake lady all right what
we got here
fuel of the eternal flame ooh that looks
like original doom art okay the
transformation of mortal creature into
demon is a laggard and gradual process
one that can take eons to transpire
without the catalyst of Argenta
intervention the victim is left a man
maunder in the shadow lands for years
uncounted we're over ageless time they
transform into demon during their
nightmarish journey the ethereal soul
slowly drains from the body and in that
dark realm the substance of mortal life
is manifest as matter it gathers in
pools of all is how aura found all over
hell demon can call these pools the well
and use them to invigorate themselves
for battle it is from this aura that the
essence is formed I'm melding it with
Wraith energy that which lights the
darkened halls and sets the Sentinel
sword ablaze the essence is founded the
combining of these primal energies
creates arjun energy a power source so
potent so incalculably formidable that
it has consumed the argenta and driven
us on to greater influence than was ever
possible with wraith power alone what's
wraith power what does that mean I don't
know how do I get down there I don't
know I'm going down I see I see I see
let me down let me down let me down let
me down
made it no demon drops what does that
even mean
okay so how am I going to get that
secret right there I didn't even need
this stupid thing okay so there's a door
there's a hallway there's a red glow
nine hundred percent sure let me go back
a bit oh it's open
okay that made it easy enough hey thanks
for the secret I don't know what that is
probably from Commander Keen or
something that's what it seemed to say
alright let's melt something who's here
who's here where is he
whoa you okay alright alright alright
okay okay hey he's easy oh yeah oh yeah
easy easy stuff baby easy stuff baby
easy stuff baby all right is that all
the secrets up until this point maybe oh
no I missed one back there because I
said I wasn't gonna deal with it then
and now look at me I've got no chance
alright but it looks like I'm actually
pretty close to almost done with this
area so I should be okay oh this is an
arene all right no thank you
wha
Wow oh here we go oh here we go ha here
we go ha ha ha ha yeah damn to you guys
well looks like it's BFG o'clock miss
wow I missed by that much
yeah baby okay all right a little more
for you yeah I think so
all right can I have some of these can I
have one of these thank you
how about one of these thank you thank
you very much whoa-oh poink uh-oh where
am i oh no no do not go okay good I
thought it was gonna be locked in the
walls well that doesn't sound good at
all actually that sounds rather bad that
sounds pretty lame you know not gonna
lie that sounds real lame looks like I
can't go back and get that BFD mo that I
was looking for but whatever who needs
it
a bunch of scrublords anyway uh-huh
uh-huh god I just love the design of
this area it's so good oh hi bud I see
you up there now how do i oh that's
Olivia Pierce what that's Olivia Pierce
from doom 2016 that's that is definitely
most certainly Olivia Pierce okay I see
why that's glowing green now I see why
Pope Pope I see why
awesome nailed it
sweet step step step step step step step
step step step step
baba Olivia see you don't know why they
who made a statue of her who in hell is
an artisan that's that's my question
right there who in hell is an artiste
who's taking the time to do this stuff
cuz this place oh that was it no no my
fast travel wait no I wasn't done I
didn't know that was gonna be it oh are
you kidding me but that I was not I
didn't see that fat I didn't see that
fast travel was I didn't see that fast I
didn't I didn't know that was it god
damn man damn it I mister talk fine it's
fine it's fine whatever
I had no frickin idea that that was
gonna be the end of that one as he make
your ascent you approach the final
floors of the Citadel where Souls are
extracted from their bodies and
converted into argent energy and in the
final stage of the makers processing
plant and use the argent conduit gain
access to her deck homeworld of the
makers where the con maker prepares the
final ritual to gain control of the icon
of sin and aleshia upon earth sounds rad
sounds super rad get punched by blood
form a back glory kill form a left side
glory kill on an arch file Oh weird okay
[Music]
okay so I got to stop this thing's
exports say no more I'm all about
disrupting the industry
okay bye just six Rockets that's it and
you die pathetic pathetic if you ask me
and you can't ask me cuz you're dead but
still pathetic can I get over there
definitely not at this pace but I can
get over there
take some of that where am I going with
this all right
I'm here now all right I feel like I'm
missing a lot of Secrets just because
the levels are starting to get a little
more convoluted oh that's my last one
baby oh yes please thank you
thank you thank you thank you very
kindly I'm now fully upgraded baby
Crucible pickups are found in the world
yeah they are Hey
Oh
what's talked about there Sammy you
sounded a really uh like evil or
something I didn't know any better I'd
say you sounded kind of evil oh I'm
supposed to do a back one to that guy oh
I forgot well I'm stuck why am I stuck
that'd be great if I wasn't stuck
could I be not stuck that'd be great if
I wasn't stuck man you are out of your
element Madhu do you are really you
shouldn't you should be running that's
all I can say about that you should be
running for your existence Oh was that
an overdrive oh I thought that was a
total mastery token not a powerup
whoops oohs all right then thank you for
that necro Vall this is one of the Seoul
spires identified in the Argentan texts
built into the central columns of necro
vol although most soul spires were
linked directly to argent DeNooyer
through a hell priests created continuum
gate this particular one is linked to
attack the homeworld of the makers there
is no continuum gate here presumably due
to the con makers natural distrust of
those under her charge the soul spires
were designed by the makers to
accelerate the process of mortal victims
into argent energy and built in secret
by Sentinel slaves under the direction
of the order de this forced labor was a
crucial step in fulfilling the con
makers desire for argent as beings from
our deck are unable to cross over to
Hell's dimension where is Hell's
leadership in all of this what do they
think about it they cool with this they
cool yeah come on in sure take all of
our [ __ ] Oh
dreadknight take it all that's fine
whatever
it airs what do we got one chain gun go
boom
easy easy when you got big boomers big
kaboom and guns big bang kaboom and guns
oh love it confetti maker party mode
cheap code okay no okay what is going on
down there I have no idea but I guess I
go down what is it's awfully blues
whoa the extracted soul remains
oh well that's a little weird but badass
that's intense
madhu chaingun go womp womp womp ma'am
oh my god oh my god goodbye Oh
whoa you're an arts file okay that's not
good yeah yeah yeah wait no that's not
the right one what oh my god really okay
left side left that was a left side one
right I did that that looked left was
that not left he said not enough left
damn it
alright whatever maybe it was oh that
was probably the one in the last one
wasn't it or was it this one I can't
remember
oh hey but welcome to the party you're a
little late hey bud how you doing what
happens if I could get this guy whoa
come on you come on come on come on come
on I'm not gonna waste it on a little
dude oh you do you think okay okay you
think
oh there we go goodbye goodbye Hey
all right what do we got here this
something
under where is that maybe behind the
waterfall maybe I can get through here
maybe no no that's a solid wall of
suffering in Souls right there
all right good I mean not good but great
I mean not great but whatever cool I
mean probably not cool but looks cool
know what I mean yeah you know what I
mean the makers need for the essence was
Prime without it they must suffer the
monsters fate of Transfiguration and see
their wisdom and faculties slither from
their twisted forms by the bidding of
the con maker self the order of the
digas devised a method to improve and
accelerate the production of the hell
aura what once took eons for the savage
beast to attain can now be accomplished
in short order by the argenta act an
intellect with greater efficiency and
consistency what did the makers do
before hell invaded they're gonna suffer
the monsters phase of Transfiguration
but weren't they around for like
millions of years before that I'm a
little confused is why they needed so
badly if they were doing fine before
that Matt whatever we constructed the
Sol spires vast halls erected in the
savage lands by our slaves and under
direction of the order even though we
raised the monument on their ground
demon kind does not Harry us during
Assembly of the soul spires for the con
maker herself bartered to deal with the
Dark Lord that rules over the shadow
walkers there we go
Dark Lord okay a bargain was struck the
demons would be given fresh worlds and
souls to consume bolstering their forces
and expanding the corrupting domain of
Hell and the makers would be granted
access to the flow of origin the
procedure inside the soul spires is thus
the captives are tortured until no
semblance of humanity remains within
them raft of hope the mortal soul is
vulnerable and can be easily extracted
this we achieve with the machine from
the enlightened mind of the con maker
herself the avulsed
one sea of ulster has done its deed and
the souls been extracted the victim's
body is ejected into the wasteland where
as before our cunning meddling it
becomes demon overtime all right sounds
like a roundabout process but badass
alright how there's something here
Hey Oh flesh and metal flesh and metal
all right so how do I get down there is
the question probably here in the big
spinning abyss I see you ha ha ha I got
him
ooh tyrant you say wow where am I going
aha whoa yes please
ok pull one up thank you alright I'm
doing good on secrets so far except for
the one there I think I missed those in
the beginning I'll try to remember if it
shows that I have the Fastpass available
earlier I should be okay
discovered and unlocked the truth the
essence they combined Sentinel and hell
energies together refinements and
created large
whether they want to save one from
extinction
he'll
power to those were the image
like me you talk about me aren't you
oh I know when someone's talking about
me oh I can tell
I got a sixth sense about these things
okay wait so the makers knew about hell
beforehand hmm I'm confused
well it was something else
ah there is I see it got it
who else file you say I like it ha ha ha
ha ha ha officials are so cool
everything about it so cool oh there we
go
it is
okay unholy you say well alright who are
you to deem what is holy and unholy
who's fighting up here why do you fight
hey calm down man
hi well this looks like a party I can
just interrupt hey bud bye bud bye
everybody apparently okay I need to go
off whoa fancy climbing walls angelic
climbing walls even very fancy I like
that
I'm hit wow that doesn't seem very holy
moly holy [ __ ] ha not that one thank you
this one please
I want to go nice okay hey hey hey I was
in the middle of killing that guy I hope
he's dead oh he's dead no more secrets
apparently I'm ro BAM and then this
looks final confrontational of some kind
all right okay
it better tell me before the level ends
the better shall be they've been
examined before the love let's Jack you
late me into their world big guy hang on
a second here hey bud I got a special
surprise for you
wha not the second time God it was my
moment and you get from me twice I was
right I am so mad at you got it when
will I be able to glory kill one of
those things just let me have it
God you suck so badly oh I'm out of ammo
okay that's a problem
oh this is a problem this is a problem
this is what wasn't a call problem not a
problem anymore here we go three two one
come on
doing you the old-fashioned way
just with some accuracy and some bullets
thank you you're dead now so these guys
job all day every day is just to hold
this thing up right that's what you're
telling me all they do all day long is
just hold this thing up cuz they got
nothing better to do then hold this
sucker up in the air that's what she was
telling me Oh interesting how do I get
down there
okay so fast travel isn't available yet
so I'm just guessing that this is not
gonna jack you late me into attack
that's just my anticipatory guess so it
better not right
oh all right I'm trusting you game how
oh oh I fell at repeted I was holding on
to that how you doing buddy
Oh guess I'll go home then
Oh finally I get a break what a doozy of
a day I got to go play some video games
oh my brother got a break for when will
I whoa
why is the icon of sin internet golf
finally time to go play animal crossing
little boo-boo
all right so now that had to have opened
up this area here a oh no it did not
interesting
very strange I open your door power
hey buddy there you are Hey one shot
stagger all right now I gotta go back to
the beginning because I gotta get the
other thing at the beginning because it
didn't let me get the thing at the
beginning so I'm gonna go right back to
the beginning damn god it just looks so
good it just looks so god damn good okay
let's try this huh nope yep all right so
it's definitely not that
okay I'm up here may whoop maybe whoop
ha boom yes yes shockingly yes I can't
believe that worked
Hey all right all right all right good
good good
up oh baby oh yeah get them before they
get you
yeah truer words never spoken
all right let's blast ourselves
something out of the sky does that got a
funny feeling that's what I got to do
sorry you just died
oh you too okay all right cool
oh I have no oh no no no no oh no no no
oh no oh no die die
yes okay we're good I'm dead what the
[ __ ] hit me what hit me
okay apparently I died so that is that
so that means that all I got to do is go
up to the tippy-top into the yards and
transmitter and then shoot myself into
attack so let's do exactly I did I'm
Jessica I just jumped I like a good leap
of faith which I guess this is is
because we're going to heaven oh right
of course this I didn't do any challenge
even though I tried I wanted to really
badly but I didn't do any challenge
because I couldn't get close enough it's
okay it's alright it's okay alright hey
I got all the collectables that's what
the cool stuff you know that's what
really matters at the end of the day
step step step
I forgot my step necros energy conduit
has transported you to err back home
world of the con maker the souls of
earth victims flow here converted into a
source of energy for a dying species the
con maker will stop at nothing to save
her doc even if it means the complete
consumption of Earth prevent her from
gaining control the icon of sin and put
an end to her plans once and for all
damn okay why are acting though I mean
if they're literally heaven maybe
they're marginally more important than
Earth it just seems like they're
technologically advanced not necessarily
divine but
game seems to combine them as one in the
same I don't know unfortunately that's
gonna be the end of this episode it
looks like we're closing up on the end
of the game the next episode might be
one of the last ones if not the last one
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]